you know the cutoff really has to be
double digits I think that's the cutoff
that's all I'm saying I think once you
hit double digits it's time to stop
trick-or-treating get off my porch and
find a job at that point once you get to
10 years old now is that with my kids
last night and and there were these
teenagers hitting the same houses that
we were hitting and there were a few few
houses at us they had no costumes they
were just putting their candy into into
their book bag so it looked like they
just got home from school and they just
decided to on the way home might as well
hit a couple houses and get some candy
and all I'm saying is it at least put
some effort into it a 16 year old not in
a costume going up to a house on
Halloween and taking candy it's like if
it's like if a five year old was invited
to his kindergarten friend's birthday
and the five year old 16 year old
brother showed up at the party right
when the cake was being cut had some
cake and left it's like it's not really
for you but if you're if you are gonna
come you should participate in the whole
thing and so in this case put on a
costume grab one of those pumpkin candy
buckets say trick-or-treat the whole
nine yards people say oh well it's
better for teenagers to be
trick-or-treating than out causing
trouble well first of all they can
multitask you know second there is a
third option they could be picking up
shifts at the coal mine okay like I did
at their age making themselves useful so
now this is for older kids
if older kids want to trick-or-treat
they have to wear costumes but once
you're not even a kid anymore once
you're an adult so at 18 years old
you're too old to trick-or-treat
obviously you're also too old to wear
costumes people don't like it when I say
this but adults should not be wearing
costumes costumes are for kids Halloween
is for kids and if you think I'm being a
Scrooge I am that's kind of my thing
but it's not just that let me give you
exhibit a look at this from yesterday
this picture here this is representative
Katey Porter a Democrat obviously at the
Capitol yesterday in a Batman costume
she's working at it she's you know doing
supposedly serious business
now wearing a Batman costume she looks
like a mental patient
this this is what happens when adults
wear costumes just look at that it's a
disgrace it's an embarrassment think
about what you're doing how do you not
look at yourself in the mirror before
you leave the house and think yourself
oh my god I'm I'm an adult dressed like
Batman how does this not cause you to
reevaluate
not just your outfit for the day but
your whole your whole life and this is
why under my administration the legal
cutoff for costumes will be 18 years old
all violators of this anyone caught in a
costume over the age of 18 will be
stuffed into a burlap sack and thrown
into the sea and as I always say I take
no pleasure in handing out those kinds
of punishments it will hurt me more than
it will hurt the person being thrown
into the ocean but it's just we have to
have law and order and this kind of
degeneracy simply cannot be tolerated
now from one katie to another speaking
of degeneracy Katie Hill you know that
lady that was having sex with her 22
year old female campaign aide paying her
with campaign funds and then allegedly
also having sex with another staffer
while you know who was also of course
being being paid this this one being
paid with with tax money she gave her
final speech before Congress yesterday
and she was not wearing a costume it
would have been kind of funny actually
if you if she was the one wearing if she
was the Katie wearing the Batman costume
giving the speech after resigning
because of ethics violations now that
would be that would be worth it but no
despite being a disgraced politician
resigning over ethics violations she
tried to turn the whole speech into some
kind of triumphant feminist moment watch
this this is the last speech that I will
give from this floor as a member of
Congress I wasn't ready for my time here
to come to an end so soon it's a reality
I'm still grappling with and I will be
for a long time to come the mistakes I
made and the people I've hurt that led
to this moment will haunt me for the
rest of my life
and I have to come to terms with that
ever since those images first came out
I've barely left my bed I've ignored all
the calls and the texts I went to the
darkest places that a mind can go and
I've shed more tears than I thought were
possible and I'm here today because so
many of the people I let down people
close to me supporters colleagues people
I've never even met told me to stand
back up and that despite all of my
faults they still believed in me and
they were still counting on me and I
realized that hiding away and
disappearing would be the one
unforgivable sin I am leaving now
because of a double standard I'm leaving
because I no longer want to be used as a
bargaining chip I'm leaving because I
didn't want to be peddled by papers and
blogs and websites used by shameless
operatives for the dirtiest gutter
politics that I've ever seen and the
right-wing media to drive cliques and
expand their audience by distributing
intimate photos of me taken without my
knowledge let alone my consent for the
sexual entertainment of millions I'm
leaving because of a misogynistic
culture that gleefully consumed my naked
pictures capitalized on my sexuality and
enabled my abusive ex to continue that
abuse this time with the entire country
watching I am leaving
because of the thousands of vile
threatening emails calls and texts that
made me fear for my life and the lives
of the people that I care about I'm
leaving because for the sake of my
community my staff my family and myself
I can't allow this to continue today as
my final act I voted to move forward
with the impeachment of Donald Trump on
behalf of the women of the United States
of America we will not stand down we
will not be broken we will not be
silenced we will rise and we will they
make tomorrow better than today now let
me ask you did you notice what was
missing from her list of reasons why she
was leaving she's leaving because of
misogyny she's leaving because of double
standards she leaves she's leaving
because of her ex-husband's just leaving
because of political operatives she's
leaving because of sexism and patriarchy
and everything but she forgot to mention
that
also leaving because she was using her
subordinates like sex toys and that's
one little detail that she seemed to
have left out I'm sure unintentionally
she just forgot to mention it of course
she's talking about double standards but
the only double standard it double
standard is the fact that she can get
away with making herself out to be
persecuted making herself the the victim
in this scenario and the media just goes
along with it
a man would not get that benefit so
that's where the double standard is in
fact the double standard is so strong in
her favor that the left now for all
intents and purposes has canceled the
me2 movement for her sake the me2
movement is cancelled now they threw it
all to the side the first time a woman
really really you know came under
scrutiny they said okay never mind on
the me2 movement thing forget it never
mind because every everything that
they've been saying about consent is now
gone all for the sake of defending this
woman because they've have been saying
all along if you're in a position of
power and someone is a subordinate they
cannot consent because they're not
because they're not on the same level of
power and they're you know they're not
going to feel like they have the ability
or like they're empowered to say no so
on and so forth those are not my rules
that's not that's not what I say now my
own personal feeling is that certainly
if you are a member of Congress having a
sexual relationship with a subordinate
in that scenario is definitely wrong and
it is an ethical violation now if we
weren't talking about Congress and when
we're talking about campaign funds and
tax money and everything and this was
just at a in a private business and you
had a you know someone in a sexual a
ship with a subordinate then it kind of
depends it's so it's sort of
situationally based I don't personally
think that it's you know it's impossible
for there to be consent or any
like that or that it's automatically
sexual assault or something I don't
personally think that but we're not
talking about my standards we're talking
about the standards set by the left by
people like Katie Hill who have been
very clear about this
they've been very clear that just
because someone says yes I want to do it
doesn't necessarily mean that it's real
consent
they've been safe said this over and
over and over again and now I guess
we're back to bad well hey I mean the
other woman wanted it so she said she
did so that's it that's all that matters
well me too movement then all right P I
guess well while we're on the subject of
detestable Democrat women which seems to
be the theme here so far let's check in
with Wendy Ullman state representative
in Pennsylvania they were debating a
bill in Pennsylvania that would require
hospitals and abortion clinics to
respectfully dispose of the remains of
unborn children because that stands
right now aborted children are tossed in
medical waste dumpsters along with used
needles and other toxic trash that's how
the human remains are treated this bill
would seek to grant just a little bit of
dignity and humanity to these humans but
Ullman is worried about this and about
the implications and she tried to
express her concerns and it didn't go so
well it refers specifically to the
product of conception after
fertilization which covers an awful lot
of territory I think we all understand
the concept of the loss of a fetus but
we're also talking about a woman who
comes into the facility and is having
cramps and there not to be not to be
concrete an early miscarriage is just
some mess on a on a napkin and I'm not
sure people would agree that this is
something that we want to take to the
point of ritual either
cremation or internment yes a a mess on
a napkin that's how she sees unborn life
as a mess on a napkin and you could tell
there right before she said that she
paused noticeably and was searching for
the right words because she knew that
what she was about to say it was
horrible and so she was looking for a
different way of putting it and this is
what she came up with so actually I
wonder in her mind she up she obviously
had she was originally gonna say say it
a different way
she had option a in her mind she was
about to say she stopped and then went
with option B so considering that this
is what she decided to say I wonder what
she originally was going to say before
she settled on this either way though
this is how this is it's it's honest I
mean this is how as a Democrat this is
how she sees unborn life she sees it as
just and it makes sense from that point
of view using that logic an unborn baby
is a clump of cells when you're aborting
a child it's just a clump of cells
basically a cancerous tumor you're
getting rid of and then in that case
yeah if an unborn child that's aborted
is a clump of cells then I guess a
miscarried child is a mess on a napkin
as she puts it now you know my we've had
miscarriages my wife's had miscarriages
and it's a very difficult thing to go
through emotionally and for the mother
physically and in fact this is what
immediately came to mind for me when I
was listening to this horrid woman
sadness one of the things that adds to
the emotional difficulty of merit of a
miscarriage is precisely that so many
people have the attitude of Allman here
the attitude that she's expressing is
exactly how a lot of people feel about
it and I even if they're not so explicit
about it
you know so many people don't really
view it when you have a miscarriage so
many people don't really view it as
losing a child and then the result is
that a woman who's going through this
she already has she's already got the
emotional burden of it but that on top
of it she feels alone and isolated as
she's mourning her miscarriage because
society doesn't see it as a big deal and
so she feels like she's got no one to
turn to and nowhere to go for empathy
because society is saying basically what
Wendy Ullman is saying which I it's just
a mess on a napkin who cares it's just
it's evil and it's vile but every time a
Democrat takes off the mask and really
says what they actually think on these
topics even though it's horrible to hear
I'm always grateful when they do because
I want people to see this the people
need to see this that this is how the
Democrat Party views human life it's
important that we all see that and then
the voters have to decide do you want to
support a political party that sees
human life this way do you agree with
that is that how you see human life you
know if you've ever had a miscarriage or
if you someone you love has had a miss
cook is that how you do you agree with
that way of looking at it if not then
you have to really evaluate whether you
can support a political party that
differs with you so dramatically in the
way that it fundamentally views human
life and that is a that is a that is a
very fundamental issue isn't it what how
we view human life what is human life is
it inherently important Democrat Party
says no if you say yes then it doesn't
mean you have to be a Republican it just
means that I think there's no way you
could support these people
okay I wanted to mention this case
speaking of vile and evil reading now a
little bit from KTLA an article on
ktla.com says the girlfriend of a boston
college student who died by suicide in
May repeatedly texted him to do so
during their relationship according to
Massachusetts prosecutors who said this
in announcing involuntary manslaughter
charges against her in young u-21
tracked Alexander Ursula's location on
May 20th and was present when he jumped
from a parking garage only hours from
graduation authorities said you also a
student of US College was physically
verbally and psychologically abusive
toward her boyfriend during their
18-month long relationship investigators
looked through a trove of text messages
the two exchanged in which you allegedly
tells Ursula who's 22 who was 22 years
old to go kill himself or to go die and
that she his family in the world would
be better off without him prosecutors
said the district attorney said you is
in her native South Korea and her office
is cautiously optimistic that you will
return to us voluntarily they're saying
they're gonna do what they can to get
her back skipping ahead a little bit
prosecutors have described a pattern of
abuse and manipulation throughout the
relationship in which you allegedly made
demands and threats an exercise total
control of hurts Allah both mentally and
emotionally she was aware of her
boyfriend's depression they contend you
instructed Ursula to kill himself
hundreds of times through the more than
47,000 text messages she sent to him
into 47,000 text messages she sent in
two months now do the math on that you
know so that's about 60 days 47,000
divided by 60 how many text messages a
day how many text messages in our it
does does that add up to Rollins said a
bill is currently in front of the
legislative committee that would make
encouragement or assistance of suicide a
crime punishable punishable up to five
years in prison now this okay and they
do bring this up this this will bring to
mind
the case of Michelle Carter a few years
ago who was convicted of involuntary
manslaughter for doing the exact same
kind of thing very similar where she
threw text messages over the course of
many weeks was trying to encourage her
boyfriend to kill himself and and on if
I remember the case correctly on the day
the night when he actually did it she
was you know he was texting with her and
saying that he was going to do it and
she was saying yes do it and encourage
me and then he did and she was convicted
with manslaughter for that now I think
there are many different directions you
could go with this with analyzing
something like this but for me I see
this this tragic disturbing case as a
sort of clear boundary line for free
speech we talk about what is free speech
what are the limits of free speech when
does speech become something more than
mere speech and I think that here we see
how that works because it's clear to me
that obviously this woman this sick
twisted woman is not covered by free
speech she has committed a crime if the
allegations are true
she has committed a crime and should be
punished severely for it I think she'd
be should be punished much more than
involuntary manslaughter
there wasn't seem to be a lot more
intention behind it than that now even
though she didn't as far as we know she
didn't physically push him over the edge
she didn't physically killed him kill
him she used other methods and those
other methods may mean that her penalty
is not as severe as it would have been
had she directly killed him but there
still has to be a penalty the method
that she used is not acceptable in a
civilized society and shouldn't be and
this is where free speech ends when
you're using speech with the intention
of directly and substantially and
maliciously harming another person the
militia in the malicious part of that is
important because if you're for example
if you're calling out a politician for
something that they've done or said well
that might harm them politically might
harm their career but it's not malicious
on your part you're justified in what
you're doing
malicious harm
through speech is is now in the case of
a politician that would be like if you
made up a lie about them to destroy them
well then that's not free speech that's
against the law and this is where the
delineation is and yes there might be
hypothetical cases where it's harder to
discern the nuances and distinguish
between whether it's free speech or not
and you're always going to have those
hard cases but in broad strokes
generally speaking there is a clear
distinction here and it is relatively
easy to tell the difference
generally speaking between these things
now some people have and this is my
point some people have tried to make
free speech into this very complicated
ambiguous thing and the people who do
that it's they're doing it for a reason
because it benefits them and usually
these are people who really don't like
free speech and but rather than come out
directly against it they just try to
make it into this ambiguous concept that
nobody can really understand but really
it's not so complicated most of the time
when you are as this woman did harassing
and tormenting someone relentlessly with
the intention of causing significant
harm to them and that is clearly what
you intend to do and why you're doing it
that's not free speech and that
obviously to me is not what the founders
intended that when the founders codified
the our first amount of free speech
rights they didn't have stuff like this
in mind I think we could be pretty
pretty sure about that
now on the other hand when you give an
opinion that lets say hurt someone's
feelings when you're speaking honestly
about your opinions on whatever subject
and someone has their feelings hurt
because of it
that is free speech and there actually
isn't that much room for confusion here
so when we talk about we get into the
free speech subject and someone says
well you know what is an example of when
it was when it could be when it should
be against the law for someone to just
say something well here we go here's an
example that I think most of us could
agree with and that's where the dividing
line is between
free speech and not for speech it's also
interesting here this was in by this was
in Boston right and so now they're
talking about passing a law that will
specifically make it illegal to do this
kind of thing to I guess encourage okay
it make encouragement or assistance of
suicide a crime punishable up to up to
five years in prison now would this
apply to so-called doctor assisted
suicide it seems like you would have to
choose between the two and anyone and
and and here's another angle we could
explore with this that anyone who hears
about the stories story of this
disgusting woman and what she did or
Michelle Carter that kind of thing if
you hear about that and you think that
is despicable and horrible and that
person needs to go to jail which I think
any civilized person that's how you
would feel about it then you should also
be against assisted suicide in every
circumstance including doctor assisted
suicide if because I think they're I
think III imagine there are a lot of
people there's kind of a cognitive
dissonance here I imagine they're
probably a lot of people who think that
doctor assisted suicide is okay but
would hear about a case like this and
think that's horrible must be against
the law now obviously there is a
difference between the cases that you
could point to there are several
differences there's no doctor involved
in you know this was this was this was
you could say manipulative and and and
all of and all of that but the fact is
it's just it's a question in society if
someone is depressed you know if someone
is going through a difficult time should
we encourage and help facilitate their
suicide or not
I would say not the right and moral and
ethical and civilized thing to do is to
help them to get to get them treatment
too and our message always has to be
your life is worth living and if that's
going to be our message if that's how we
should approach you know this this issue
then I think you can't have doctors it's
so called doctor assisted suicide or or
this I think I think both of them go out
the window
and you know the Pete the people who
would say well it's it's different
because you got a doctor involved
getting a doctor involved in in many
ways makes it worse because it's a total
perversion of medicine think about the
Hippocratic oath do no harm medicine is
supposed to be about treating disease
helping people treating people curing
people making them healthier that's what
medicine is supposed to be there
shouldn't be a time in medicine where we
are directly killing people on purpose
that's not medicine all right let's move
on emails Matt Walsh show at gmail.com
Matt Walsh show at gmail.com this is
from let's see here from John says hi
Matt I like your show and your activism
that said I think your n-c-double-a take
is wrong basically your point is that
you're not Pro free market if you think
the rule that n-c-double-a athletes
can't use their name to make money is
fair however I think you forget the
essence of free-market freedom of
contracts no one forced these athletes
to enter into a contract in which a
clause or name and likeness with such a
clause on name and likeness on the
contrary athletes enter these contracts
because they believe that even with such
clauses the contract benefitted them
they better fit with scholarships fame a
chance to make it in the pro in the pros
etc now you might think that the deal is
unfair that the NCAA want it makes too
much money that the athletes may
to little but that's irrelevant the
athletes in a free-market environment
use their freedom of contracts to enter
into these agreements because they
believe that they end up better off with
the agreement than without they got what
they bargained for in a free-market
environment to the contrary if you pass
a law or a Court decision saying that
the athletes cannot contract
contractually waive their rights to use
their name and likeness you are going
against free market the same way a
minimum wage law would this is exactly
like a minimum wage because you would be
saying no even if you want to you cannot
legally go below this threshold but what
if I'm starting to work and I'm willing
I'm willing to work for five dollars an
hour no you can what if I'm willing to
waive my right to use my name to get a
scholarship to get into ends
n-c-double-a and get a scholarship no
you can't it's the same thing of course
from the free market perspective it's
totally fine at the n-c-double-a decide
on its own or after bargaining with the
athletes to let them use their name yeah
well that's what you said at the end
there it's kind of the crux of it
because what we talked about a few days
ago was the n-c-double-a was deciding
that they were going to allow athletes
and we didn't get into specifics yet as
far as I know so there's a lot that has
to be hashed out here but the basic
broad-stroke here is that they are going
to allow athletes to puff it off of
their name and image and then you have
the government coming in and saying or
at least one politician coming in saying
he's going to propose a law that would
penalize students who take advantage of
that and decide to profit off of their
name and image so that I assume you
would agree is anti free market where
now you've got a contract between the
NCAA and these athletes and then you've
got the government coming in and saying
no no we don't like that and so we're
gonna punish you for it
that obviously is not free market also I
would say that I have been pushing for
this myself I think that this is this
the n-c-double-a should allow this
that's not an anti free-market view on
my part you know I never said that the
n-c-double-a necessarily didn't have the
didn't have the right to prevent
athletes from making money in this way
it wasn't a matter of did they have the
right to do I didn't say they have a
right to it I said it's not right so
they might
the right to make these kinds of rules
preventing athletes from profiting off
of their own name and image but I think
it's wrong and this is a this is a
distinction that people struggle with a
lot I'm not exactly sure why because
this happens a lot we're all say okay
this and that it you know I think that
such-and-such is wrong and you shouldn't
do that and then inevitably I'll get the
emails from people saying oh you're
saying we shouldn't have the right to do
that no that's not what I'm saying if I
think that you shouldn't have the right
to do it then I'll say that that's a
separate argument but there are a lot of
things that we have the right to do as
individuals or as organizations as
companies whatever that I still think we
shouldn't do because it's not right it's
unethical it's immoral in my opinion and
so that's my argument and third point is
that you know wouldn't you've got I
don't think that your comparison exactly
works because with the n-c-double-a this
is this massive organization controlling
all of these schools across the country
passing these rules from on high telling
athletes that they can't go on their own
because we're not even talking about
making an income saying that they can't
even go in their own private life and
sell a jersey or something now prior to
this rule change they're talking about
that was what they were saying so it's
hard for me to not see I don't know how
you could see that as anything but a
violation of free-market principles I
don't know how you could say that that
is consistent with the free market
because even in in the example of
Walmart with the minimum wage that
you're talking about yeah what you you
enter into a contract with Walmart about
what your salary is gonna be but
Walmart's not gonna tell you that when
you leave and go home you can't sell
something on Craigslist and if Walmart
did try to pass a rule like
telling employees that even when they go
home and are on their own time they're
not allowed to go on Craigslist and sell
something of theirs I would say that
that certainly isn't consistent with the
free market and and whether or not they
that they should have the legal right to
pass a rule like that well that would be
a discussion we could have but it's
there's certainly a question about
whether or not they would this is from
Leslie says hi Matt I do I do the
grocery shopping every week for my
family I have to go during school hours
so I don't have to drag around little
humans that hang off my buggy and dabble
in petty thievery I tend to go late
mornings to try to miss restocking so I
can rush through and tackle my list but
lately there seems to be a recurring
issue of larger humans standing in the
middle of the aisles texting on their
phone and looking annoyed when I say
excuse me to try to get around them
during your dictatorship would you
please summon these people immediately
to an American Gladiator styled demise
with those big q-tip looking bats and a
vat of alligators thank you in advance
for your ruling Leslie you have
identified one of the great threats to
human civilization that we face and not
just in supermarkets but everywhere
people who stand in walking aisles you
know walking lanes aisles sidewalks
clogging up foot traffic people who walk
too slow people who stand in the walking
path of those moving walkways at the
airport where they're supposed to be one
side you stand one side you walk with
their people who stand in the walking
aisle this is all it's an epidemic I
agree it's chaos as for the penalty
under my regime I like how you're you
know I like I like your thought process
I like the creativity but here's my
thought anyone who blocks an aisle or
stands when they should be walking or
walks too slow will have their legs
amputated because if you aren't gonna
use them then you lose them that's the
basic principle here and by the way that
principle will also apply to people who
don't make sufficient use of their
brains as well use it or lose it is
going to be the rule under my regime
this is from Andrew says why do you
think people why do people think an
impeachment is good for Trump I'm seeing
all over Twitter mid-level conservative
figures declare that what the house is
doing is an automatic win for Trump in
2020 is that
really the case well the only way that
it's bad for Trump is if he actually
gets thrown out of office which isn't
gonna happen so the problem for
Democrats is that they're really as far
as I can tell there really isn't
anything for them to gain from this
politically speaking the anti Trump
voters who love the impeachment stuff
well they're gonna vote for Democrats
regardless the Democrats didn't need to
do this to win the votes of the rapidly
anti-trump voters because they're gonna
vote against Trump no matter what the
Democrats do the issue then is then is
is how does it play with people who are
in the middle and people who are
center-right the people who are in the
middle or center or center-right and
don't really like Trump and are kind of
sick of his ol act and could be
convinced to vote against him but are
concerned about the extremism and the
craziness on the left the question is
now Democrats they need to win a good
chunk of those voters the question is
this impeachment pageant is it going to
help them win those people or is it more
likely to a lien eight those people and
I would say almost certainly the letter
this is from Rebecca says Matt what are
your thoughts on Q well Rebecca you
didn't I was trying to figure out when I
read this email what are your thoughts
on Q you didn't stipulate what exactly
you're referring to so you could be
asking for my general thoughts on the
letter Q and as far as that goes I'm a
fan of the letter I don't I don't think
it's a top-five member of the alphabet
but it's not bad you could be asking me
about the whole Q anon thing and as for
that I don't believe any of that because
I'm not a [ __ ] or you could be asking
me about the Q source which is the
hypothetical source Matthew and Luke
used to write their Gospels and as the
theory goes Matthew and Luke based their
gospel accounts on mark but they also
had a second source which would have
been a collection of Jesus's sayings
without any narrative so sort of like
the apocryphal Gospel of Thomas and I'm
gonna pretend that you meant to ask me
about that
because that is the most interesting q
related thing that we could talk about
in my opinion and and though I'm not a
proponent of the queue theory I think
inventing a hypothetical gospel that
nobody has ever seen is sort of absurd
and and far too complicated when there
are simpler more logical explanations so
it's clear that Matthew and Luke you
know Matthew Mark and Luke are the
synoptic Gospels of course we call them
synoptic because they're so similar it's
clear that they did use mark as a source
because and we know that because they
repeat mark almost verbatim at many
different places in their accounts so
there's just no reasonable way to
explain the similarities other than
other than they used mark and besides in
the preamble to Luke's Gospel he says
that he consulted other sources and so
it makes sense that he would have
consulted in earlier gospel like Mark
although he doesn't specifically say
mark that doesn't make sense the issue
though and where people get this cue
thing from is that while Matthew and
Luke repeat marked verbatim at various
points they also mirror each other
verbatim at other points but not mark
and so the question is where did they
get that almost identical content that
isn't in mark then so the the theory is
there must be some other third thing
they looked at that they were both using
independently without knowing that the
other one was using it and but my thing
is you know why couldn't it been like
this mark writes his gospel first and as
tradition has it mark is was a was a of
a follower of Peter and a associate of
Peter so would have gotten a lot of his
material from Peter and then Matthew
writes his gospel and uses mark and also
his own recollections as an eyewitness
apostle and then Luke writes third and
he uses both Matthew and Mark and then
has his own material that he gets from
from his own sources so there's no need
for cue and it seems to be simpler and
it makes more sense you know that way in
my view all right finally from Tim and I
just answered a question that you almost
certainly probably were not trying to
ask
from Tim says hi Matt I don't believe in
divorce but have you considered it with
your refrigerator problem
yeah I've been talking about this on
Twitter my wife has well it all started
I think with the syrup she started
putting our syrup in the refrigerator
and I originally I didn't say anything
because I thought okay it's not not a
big deal it's just syrup so when I found
the syrup in the fridge I would take it
because you don't you don't need to put
syrup in the fridge they syrup will stay
good forever you know syrup will outlast
the plastic that it's in it will outlast
the bottle that it's in syrup is just
kids will stay good for a million years
that's just science as far as I know
although it could be wrong probably so
she started putting syrup in the fridge
and I didn't say anything and then and
then she started putting peanut butter
in the fridge and that's when I started
making Commons and saying you know we
don't need to put peanut butter and
syrup in the fridge is it can just go in
the pantry but then she started putting
honey in the fridge too honey I mean
honey is it it usually is in a beehive
which is not refrigerated in fact
beehives are very warm inside bees keep
hives warm even in though even in the
even in the wintertime because with the
vibration of their bodies they they heat
up the the inside of the hive so that
it's at like 98 degrees inside the hive
tried to explain this to my wife she
didn't care so now we got we've got
honey syrup and peanut butter going in
the fridge and every time I see it I
take it out and put it in the pantry and
she puts it back in the fridge and we
got cask on her well yesterday I opened
off the fridge last night and I find
honey syrup peanut butter and bananas in
the fridge
she's now putting bananas in the
refrigerator bananas are tropical fruits
you get them in the jungle they don't
need to be in a refrigerator there's no
refrigeration in the jungle and you know
what happened I I tried to talk to my
wife about this calmly and I said you
know I think we have a problem here
I think that you have a compulsion you
have a refrigerator refrigerator related
compulsion we need we can we can get
help for this though it's it's okay you
know what you did
laughter the refrigerator abuse is not a
laughing matter I don't know where it's
gonna end before all of our kitchen
items are gonna end up in the
refrigerator she's gonna start putting
like the toaster in the refrigerator
this is this is but you know as I've
been talking about this on Twitter I've
discovered that a lot of people out
there are dealing with similar problems
in their home where they've got one
spouse or the other who thinks that
everything should be refrigerated and so
this is an unspoken issue in America
that I'm glad that I could bring this
for this conversation to the forefront
because we need to talk about it the
refrigerator is a is a is an important
and powerful tool it has specific uses
and to abuse it in this way is dangerous
and and offensive to me on a personal
level and we'll leave it there thanks
everybody for watching have a great
weekend Godspeed
Matt Walsh show is produced by Robert
Sterling associate producer alexia
Garcia Del Rio executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Donovan Fowler audio
is mixed by Mike Cora Mena the Matt
Walsh show is a daily wired production
copyright V Lee Weyer 2019 if you prefer
facts over feelings aren't offended by
the brutal truth and you can still laugh
at the insanity filling our national
news cycle well tune in to the Ben
Shapiro show we will get a whole lot of
that and much more see you there